[Music]
we are at the Warner Brothers lot you
may not know that watching at home and
but the Warner Brothers lot where we
tape is a great place to be for the
holidays and I'll tell you why
Warner Brothers they've been around
forever they have this amazing library
of amazing incredible TV shows stuff
that goes way back they have rare
directors cuts of all the holiday shows
we grew up watching on television stuff
you've never seen before I want to show
you this check out this footage that was
cut from the original Rankin ambass 1970
classic Santa Claus is coming to town
they took this scene out but we found it
there's all kinds of ways we can help
each other you can bring me nice new
toys and I can assist you with my magic
Wow
I'll show you gaze into my magic crystal
snowball someone is looking for you
[Applause]
[Music]
I look a lot like that guy oh yeah the
Santa guy you mean ya puppet right
everyone understood what I was talking
about Ronnie man I met the dude on
that's me in a moment of ecstasy right
there oh that's me that's me and a
moment of passion it's the suit I wear
and everything